- [Instructor] So after
getting a very late start,
the English finally
started a New World colony
on the coast of North America in 1607,
and it was here at Jamestown.
The English colonists at
Jamestown could not have been
less prepared to settle a New World.
They came from the Virginia Company,
which was a joint-stock company,
or kind of like a modern-day corporation,
which was trying to make
wealth for its shareholders
as quickly as possible.
Now, if you think about
people in this time period,
they in England are taking
a look over at Spain
and seeing Spain bring ships
full of gold and silver
back to Europe from the New
World, and they wanna get in
on that action.
And as far as they know,
the whole New World
is just piled up with silver and gold.
So in the first months,
they sent gentlemen,
and the English definition
of a gentleman here is
someone who does not work with his hands,
to try to find gold
in Virginia.
Now, spoiler alert, there
is no gold in Virginia.
But that whole first summer,
when they were there,
they could have been planting crops,
they could have been fishing,
I mean this is actually
a pretty bountiful area when
it comes to natural resources
in plants and animals.
But they were trying to find
gold, they were trying to
basically get rich quick,
this was the scheme.
But then winter rolled around.
Those who hadn't already
been killed by mosquito-borne
illnesses, like malaria
or yellow fever, were now
subject to starvation.
And there the story gets
even more complicated,
because the English settlers,
who were all men, by the way,
they were adventurers, they were not there
to start families,
start a long-term colony
in the New World, they just
wanted to find gold and get out.
So as these English colonists
are starving, they start to
run afoul of local Native Americans.
There were an Algonquian tribe
living in the Virginia
tidewater, who were under
the rule of this man here.
This is a drawing of him
done by John Smith, who we'll
talk about in a second.
His name was Powhatan.
His real name was Wahunsunacawh,
but the English called him
Powhatan, and the people
that he ruled, the Powhatans.
And as the English settlers
realized that they had not
put away enough for practically
any stores to get them
through the winter, they started
raiding the food supplies
of the Powhatans, which,
of course, didn't make them
very happy, they were also
trying to survive the winter.
Then the Powhatans kidnapped John Smith,
and there's an engraving of him here.
Uh, and they kinda tried
to show him their power.
So there's a legend that
Powhatan was intending to execute
John Smith.
The daughter of Powhatan,
Pocahontas also wasn't her
real name, that was her
nickname, it kinda meant
little playful person.
Her real name was Matoaka,
but we know her today
by her nickname, Pocahontas.
And Pocahontas intervened
and kept her father
from executing John Smith,
either out of the goodness
of her heart or maybe because
she had a crush on him.
This is pretty much completely untrue.
The Disney version of this
story says that Pocahontas
and John Smith go on to fall
in love and get married.
The fact of the matter was that Pocahontas
was probably about 13
years old at the time.
And she will go on to marry an Englishman,
but not John Smith, John Rolfe,
who is famous in another
way, which we'll get to soon.
It's also quite likely that
Powhatan didn't actually intend
to execute Smith.
Instead, what he was
doing was kind of a ritual
of power and mercy,
so he's doing kind of a mock execution,
saying, "All right, I have
the power to execute you."
But then, Pocahontas, playing
her ritual role, steps in
to say, "No, have mercy."
So he says, you know, "I could kill you
"because I'm a strong leader,
"but because I an also a
merciful and just leader,
"I will not."
So after his kidnapping, John
Smith really kinda steps up
as the savior of Jamestown,
which probably would have
completely collapsed were it not for him.
And in 1608, he takes over and says that,
"He who shall not work shall not eat."
So you gotta pull your weight
if you're gonna get supported
by the rest of the colonists.
Nevertheless, the first
years at Jamestown were
pretty rough.
In the winter of 1609 to
1610, which they called
the starving time, the
colonists were so hungry that
they resorted to eating vermin,
and they resorted to eating each other.
One man actually killed and
ate his wife in one of the
few known examples of English cannibalism.
So Jamestown was a
pretty rough place to be.
Only about 15%
of the settlers who went to
Jamestown actually survived.
In fact, that following spring of 1610,
they decided to give up
and head back to England.
They were met, just as they were leaving,
by new supply ships
that continued the Virginia experiment,
which will become much more
successful after the discovery
of tobacco.
We'll get to that in the next video.